foreign
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Kristen bursack I'm a
principal scientist with mommetus and
I'm really excited to share with you
some of our latest work on an
endothelium on a chip model where we're
able to track and quantify 3D cell
migration
so at momedis we develop human tissue
models as well as disease models for
better therapies so the idea is that
we're able to unlock novel biology
through our models
um have these better and faster assays
to ultimately have an impact on drug
development
and we develop our models in this
platform this High throughput organ on a
chip platform called the organoplate now
the organoplate bottom is pictured here
it's made up of microscope quality glass
and in between the glass are these
microfluidic channels
now the top of the organoplate may be a
little bit more familiar to you because
it looks quite similar to a 384 well
plate
and here you can use a pipette or an
automated liquid Handler to add your
cells extracellular Matrix or media
within the wells to the microfluidic
channels so that you have these tissues
that you're building
layer by layer within those channels
so now I'm going to play a video for you
that should give you a good idea of how
the organoplate works
so here's an example of the organoplate
three Lane 40. there's 40 chips on a
single plate and if we zoom in on one of
the chips we see that we have three
lanes running in parallel
the top middle and bottom channels and
there's no physical barriers that
separate those instead there's these
short Ridges of plastic called phase
guides they act as capillary pressure
barriers so when you pipette in an
extracellular Matrix gel like collagen
it keeps it within that Central Channel
and prevents spillover
and once it's solid we can add cells to
the perfusion channel in medium and they
are in direct contact with that ECM that
you added
and once they've attached to the ECM we
can begin perfusion by placing the whole
plate on a rocker based system within
the incubator
and here the wells act as medium
reservoirs such that while the plate
rocks One Direction the media flows
through the microfluidic channels and
then it's programmed to rock the other
direction
towards the other microfluidic Wells
and so over time when you have cells in
that channel we see that this 3D
tubule-like structure often forms
mimicking say like a blood vessel and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
soon
so there are four different flavors of
organoplates and I think the simplest is
the organoplate tooling this one has 96
individual tissue chips on a single
plate
um and in this case we only have you
know two lanes running in parallel so
there's an ECM Channel and a perfusion
Channel separated by a single phase
guide
an example of a tissue weight we might
have here is say liver cells we may
embed them in an ECM
and that bottom gel Channel
to add complexity to the culture you
might want a third lane or a third
Channel and this is why we have the
three lane 40 which you actually just
saw in the video this was our first
generation of the three lane has 40
chips on one plate
um and in maybe this case you want to
increase complexity by having a blood
vessel in that top perfusion Channel and
maybe
um a proximal tubule even in the bottom
perfusion Channel
the next is the three lane 64 which we
developed a little bit later it has
increased throughput compared to the 40.
but it's also quite compatible with
automated liquid handling and any
instruments that you may work with to
increase your throughput perhaps for a
drug screen
so finally we have the organoplate craft
where it's a little bit of a variation
on the three Lane in this case you have
the three channels again but the ECM
channel is open on top and it enables
you to graft in a piece of tissue of an
organoid or a spheroid on top of that
ECM which could contain say even a
vascular bed
foreign
so now I want to switch gears a little
bit and introduce the topic of immune
cell migration
I think this is a really important
process in a lot of different diseases
and inflammatory States so we would
really benefit from being able to model
this in vitro
and so there's a number of different
processes that occur in our bodies with
immune cell migration so typically
there's first an inflammatory signal
that occurs in the tissue and it signals
to our circulating white blood cells and
once our white blood cells become
activated
they begin the process of migration so
they'll tether and roll really
interacting with the endothelium
adhering and crawling before they
finally transmigrate and will undergo
chemotaxis and tissue trafficking
and I think a really good question now
is can we model this outside of the body
and
I think there really is a need for novel
and vitro immune migration models
um
and this is particularly because some of
the the in Vivo models that are out
there some of them are are good and they
work for their purpose however we do
know that there's a quite a lot of
differences between the immune system of
an animal as well as a from a human so
the translatability is often Limited
for some of the current and future
models that are out there there are some
drawbacks including the fact that they
typically lack an endothelial blood
vessel and as we just saw in the
previous slide we know how important the
interaction between the immune cells and
the endothelial cells are to achieve
migration
so we don't have the expression of
adhesion molecules we don't get that
extra visation without the endothelial
cells
additionally these models tend to lack
any perfusion and again we know that
this happens in Vivo right we have blood
flowing and it's while the our white
blood cells are flowing that they're
actually triggered to migrate into the
tissue
some of the the migration models that
are out there they're typically driven
by gravity so you have one chamber on
top another chamber on bottom and it's
really gravity that that kind of allows
the cells to move from one to the other
and typically there's a synthetic
membrane present there
and we know in in our bodies you know we
of course we don't have these synthetic
membranes
um but typically it's also gradients
that drive the migration of the immune
cells
and then finally there are some complex
other complex models out there that can
recapitulate many of these
physiologically relevant features
however they tend to be more low
throughput where you can only compare a
few conditions at one time
um so I think that yeah it would be
really beneficial to have
um a high throughput model where you can
have multiple conditions compared
perhaps even doing a screen with with
drugs at different concentrations
so that leads me nicely into this next
slide and I hope you can already see
that the organoplate offers and
addresses many of the drawbacks
especially of the current in vitro
models that are out there we're membrane
free we have perfused cultures we have
nice throughput levels and we're quite
compatible with the typical laboratory
equipment that's already out there as
well as for automating and really
scaling up to a high throughput screen
okay so for the rest of my talk I'd
really like to focus on a case study
where we use the organoplate three-lane
to incorporate
many of those physiologically relevant
aspects of immune cell migration and so
this work was carried out in principle
by our Netherlands team so Luke and
Laney who are featured here and they did
this work in collaboration with Merck
[Music]
so the first thing that the team wanted
to do was to to form you know the very
first basic structure and that's the
blood vessel right before we jump into
the complex co-culture let's see if we
can culture one of the cell types alone
and that was so that was the formation
of our blood vessel we did this using
the hmac one cells these are
immortalized endothelial cells
um and so we seeded first the ECM in the
gel Channel Once that was solid we added
the hmx to the top perfusion channel in
medium allowed them to attach to the gel
and then after some time and some
perfusion we actually found that a
tubular tubular like structure kind of
mimicking a blood vessel formed within
that topper Fusion Channel
so we can actually fix the cultures
directly in the plate and do some
immunostaining so that's what we did
over on the right hand side here
um and then from there we did some some
nice confocal Imaging we can because
it's a 3D culture we had to you know
image not only one plane but image
multiple Z slices throughout the height
of the the profusion Channel then we can
stitch them together and make this 3D
reconstruction
um and so that's what we're seeing here
in this top image is a 3D reconstruction
of the tubule where you're actually
looking directly through the tubule so
in this case you have endothelial cells
lining the full you know microfluidic
Channel really mimicking that blood
vessel structure
and you can see that we've stained for
cd31 so where and that's in Red so quite
positive for one of the phenotypic
markers of endothelium which is great
and I think it's harder to see you know
more detailed localization in this 3D
reconstruction so in that case we ended
up taking some you know more area
specific images higher magnification
down below where we can see cd31
expression a little bit better as well
as Von willebron Factor so really just
confirming that we have this blood
vessel phenotype
when the cells are cultured alone
so gearing up to to adding the immune
cells we wanted to make sure that the
blood vessels were compatible with the
immune cell medium
and so in this case we grew our blood
vessels and we evaluated the function of
the blood vessels
in the presence of the immune cell
medium and the function test that we did
is called the barrier function test
because we know that tight junctions and
barriers barrier function is really
indicative of healthy blood vessels
and so in this case we can see in the
top right images when we don't have any
cells in our top perfusion Channel and
we add a fluorescent dye that because
there's no cells blocking the dye from
diffusing through the channels we
actually see a whole green chip
and that's what we expect however when
we have grown the hmac-1 vessels in that
top perfusion Channel
we we know we have those cells that are
lining all the way around the the
microflitic channels and lining the the
ECM
um and so by adding the die we can
actually see that the tight junctions
especially of those cells that are
lined along the ECM are maintaining a
nice barrier function because the dye is
not able to perfuse into that gel
Channel or the bottom perfusion Channel
and so we can track this over time so
take a series of images over
a few minutes and calculate what's
called a parent permeability or the piap
value that's what we can see in the
bottom graph
um and the higher the p app value is the
higher the permeability so
um that's what we see with the the no
cell controls however when we do have
the hmac blood vessels present we see
our apparent permeability is much low
much lower I'm indicating that we have a
nice barrier function
and what we can see is when we measure
this both on day six and day eight that
we have this nice stable
barrier formation over that time and it
really demonstrated a clear assay window
for us and a time when we could
confidently add our T cells to the
culture
okay so the next thing we wanted to do
is make sure we could visualize and
actually quantify the T cells within the
microfluidic channels
so here we took T cells and we stained
them with a cell tracker a fluorescent
cell tracker added them to the blood
vessel side and you can see them in red
in the top images kind of overlaid on
top of a phase contrast image
so you can really see when we first add
the cells you have a couple red dots
within that top perfusion Channel which
makes sense because they were just added
and then by 48 hours you're starting to
get a little bit of migration and more
interaction with the blood vessel
and so we were able to develop an image
analysis algorithm where we could
quantify the cells that are attached to
the blood vessel
as well as those that have migrated into
the ECM
and another method in addition to being
able to count those we can also
determine where within the chip the
cells are located most so on the y-axis
of this top right graph we can see the
distance that the immune cells or the T
cells have traveled so if they're mostly
towards the top towards the zero 400
then we know we're in that top perfusion
Channel then you can see the middle
section as if they're in the gel and
then the bottom section is if they've
made it all the way down to that bottom
perfusion channel so we can not only
count them but also tell where within
the chip the cells are located
[Music]
foreign
ly we can do some immunofluorescent
staining as we were talking about
earlier and here this is really nice to
see the interaction between the immune
cells and the blood vessel and we can
see cd45 positive in T cells
are are interacting nicely with the
blood vessel in the top perfusion
Channel and have are already kind of
wiggling through and migrating into the
ECM
[Music]
Okay so
the next thing that we wanted to do was
to try and see if there was a difference
between unstimulated t cells and
stimulated T cells because we know this
that both situations happen in the in
Vivo and typically stimulated T cells in
Vivo are produced by interacting with
antigen presenting cells um that might
Express cd30 but CD3 or cd28 so we're
able to stimulate the T cells by using
beads that had those those antigens
expressed
um and so we compared the two and then
monitored the T cells first how they
adhered to the blood vessel and what we
can see in this top right graph
is
um that there was some
over time there was an increase in the
adhesion of the the cells to that blood
vessel particularly in those that were
stimulated there was also an effect in
unstimulated I would say it was a bit
more dramatic in those that were
stimulated
we also wanted to see what would happen
um
when the cells migrated and in this case
we actually saw that the there was not
really a difference between the
unstimulated and the stimulated T Cell
populations when it came to migration
into that ECM Channel
which if you think about it makes a
little bit of sense right because we
didn't actually have any triggers
telling them to necessarily to to
migrate or anything
um
yeah in that direction
so we can confirm the viability of the T
cells by staining the cultures with
calcium am so here we're confident that
any cells that did migrate they are
viable because they're quite positive
and green nice and green that overlays
with the this T Cell tracker marker
[Music]
so we can also determine the interaction
between the T cells and the vasculature
and I think this is pretty cool so we
want to understand how the T cells
affect the vasculature and one of the
first questions we had was whether when
we added those T cells if they disrupted
the the type Junctions or the barrier
formation of the blood vessels
um and so we added a combination a
number of different um
combinations of cultures here so we had
um you know a situation where we had no
blood vessel at all that's the first
condition in the top left graph then we
had only a blood vessel then we had
either with or without or stimulated or
unstimulated T cells added to the
cultures
and really we can see that
there's not really a big difference and
that adding the T cells you know
unstimulated or stimulated did not have
a great impact on the barrier function
of the hmex cells you may see just a
slight increase in the piap value when
we added stimulated cells after 48 Hours
however this was not significantly
different from unstimulated or even a
situation where we didn't have T cells
in the culture
next we wanted to understand
how adding these T cells impacted the um
those adhesion molecules that are really
important for for T Cell transmigration
and so one of those is icam1 and so what
we did is we you know added our
unstimulated and stimulated T cells
compared to our no T Cell condition and
after 48 hours we measured icam
expression in the tubules
um
and what we see is you know after adding
the unstimulated T cells there was not
really a difference between you know no
T cells at all however when you added
the stimulated T cells there was quite
an up regulation of icam1 expression in
those endothelial markers really
suggesting that the T cells are perhaps
maybe secreting something or expressing
something that's um
creating this upregulation of this this
marker
so we did investigate that a little bit
further
and we found that the cells that were
stimulated had a much higher level of
interferon gamma and so this makes a lot
of sense interferon gamma is known to
cause an upregulation of icam1 so we
suspect that the the stimulated T cells
are up regulating icam1 for this reason
so here we have a nice video for you
this is a 3D reconstruction of a tubule
where we have the endothelial cells and
then the immune cells are actually in
green they're CD3 positive T cells and
you can just see how they're really
nicely interacting with the the blood
vessel
throughout the chip
and in this case you also see that we
have quite some T cells that have
migrated into that gel Channel and we
haven't seen that much yet to this point
with the data set that I've shared
and that's because in this chip we
actually used
a chemokine gradient
so we do know that you know T cells are
usually in the bloodstream
unless you know they're called by
chemokine gradients that are produced by
the tissue and there's a number of
different chemokines and chemokine
receptors that are are out there and
that's what this top left image really
depicts for you a nice summary of that
and and one of them that is really well
known to
um interact with T cells is cxcl12 and
so in our cultures what we decided to do
was to add cxcl12 to that bottom
perfusion channel so if you look to the
top right image to this little cartoon
that we have there's kind of this purple
Hue and that bottom perfusion channel so
that purple represents the cxcl12 that
we added to the cultures
so in the bottom left Channel
we first we tried this with a
fluorescent version of of our growth
factor and what we see is that there's
just this stable
gradients that's formed at one hour and
it's really maintained out to 48 hours
you can see that you know we have most
of the the growth factors is that purple
color I'm sorry is the orange color
um so it's mostly in that bottom
profusion Channel however as you
increase you know yellow green you're
you're getting towards
you know lower levels of the the growth
factor towards that top perfusion
Channel
and we can actually also measure this
over time using an Elisa so in the
bottom right image we simply sampled
some of the media over time
and determined that the growth factor
was in fact making it to that top
perfusion Channel but of course you
notice it's a very small percentage as
compared to you know what would be in
that bottom profusion channel so we're
only around one or two percent but over
time it does increase
um towards that top perfusion Channel
where our blood vessel is present with
the immune cells
so yeah that's that's a little bit what
that video started to show for you
um and here's some more some more images
describing that exactly so we had
first in this top left image uh this is
just a maximum projection so looking
from the top down you can see our green
immune cells are within the blood vessel
but there's also quite a few that are
within the the ECM and have migrated
there
and then I think our 3D reconstructions
help us to understand a little bit
better where the cells are in a 3D space
um and in this case when you turn the
culture on its side really long
the z-axis and this bottom image you can
see that the green immune cells are are
really throughout the height of the the
gel Channel
and we can also see that the T cells are
really affected differently that
depending on their activation state so
in this top image we have first the
number of T cells that had simply
adhered within that blood vessel
um and what we can see is if we first
look at the unstimulated T cells we see
that when we add cxcl12 there's this
nice increase in the number of cells
that are able to migrate uh through that
ECM I'm sorry that are able to adhere to
the blood vessel
however when you look at the stimulated
cells there's not actually a huge
difference of when we add the cxcl12 is
when we don't have the cxcl12 and I
think that's because there's already
this Baseline of when we add those
stimulated T cells they're already
interacting quite a bit with the
endothelium and binding there
now when we look at migration I think
the story is a little bit different
in this case we didn't have a lot of
migration going on when there was no
when the T cells were unstimulated
however when we did have stimulated T
cells present the cxcl12 made a huge
difference in the migration status of
the T cells we had a lot more regular a
lot more
um
migration occurring at 24 and then also
at 48 hours
so it really demonstrates I think that
um
the activation State clearly impacts how
the immune cells interact with the
endothelium and interact with a
chemokine gradient
so one thing I think that's important to
point out is we know that the immune
system
is really complex and that there's often
variations you know within individuals
and also between individuals I think
we're actually able to capture both and
I bring that up because you see that
there's especially in this left-hand
graph there's just quite a spread in
some of the data points even within a
single group
so I think really just representing
those differences that occur you know
even within an individual but to try to
understand a little bit better
differences between
that was within an individual this is
between individuals we evaluated T cells
from various three different donors and
we applied the same triggers to
stimulated the T cells added cxcl12 and
you can see
especially by the time we get to 48
hours there's just quite a spread in the
three different donors in three
different colors here so blue red and
purple
um so it just it seems like you know
this can really vary between individuals
and it becomes more apparent with the
the more co-culture time
so I think this also suggests that the
model can be used to evaluate
differences between individuals and even
thinking down the line trying to
understand how a therapy might affect a
particular individual
so now we wanted to understand how
different inflammatory markers that were
present within the vasculature
um are present within circulation may
actually
induce vascular inflammation and
upregulate those adhesion molecules so
before we were looking at upregulation
of adhesion molecules in response to the
the T cells themselves now we're
thinking about other inflammatory
markers that might be present in
circulation including tnf Alpha
so here we added tnf Alpha to the blood
vessels before adding the immune cells
and what we found was that
um
so on the right hand side we have some
nice immunostaining of the icam1 once
again based on the tnf alpha so we have
tnf Alpha and increasing concentration
all the way down here and what we
observed which is a little bit maybe
easier to see in the graph where we
Quantified this is that in the absence
of T cells and in the presence of
unstimulated T cells we see a bit of a
dose-dependent increase in the
expression of icam1
however in the situation where we added
stimulated T cells so this is the right
portion of the rightmost portion of the
graph with the red dots we don't see
that dose dependent increase but you
already see a much higher level starting
at even the zero of T and F Alpha so
really suggesting that the T cells
themselves are causing this kind of
Baseline activation of the endothelium
so the next thing we wanted to do was to
try and block extravasation of those T
cells so this could have therapeutic
consequences we just so we wanted to see
are we able to really inhibit that
migration and so in this case we added
both the trigger cxcl12 to the bottom
as well as an inhibitor and you can see
so we had two different Inhibitors so
the bottom most images demonstrate less
cell migration
than that top image on the right hand
side where we had the the trigger in the
vehicle or the trigger only so here we
really demonstrate that we're able to
test different compounds and conditions
to see if we can reverse or inhibit
migration
so you as you can imagine you know we we
only also don't only have our blood
vessels and our T cells present in um in
our bodies we also have present tissue
right so we may be we were really
interested in introduce increasing the
complexity of the culture by adding
um you know a tissue that might produce
its own chemokine gradient and in this
case this hop happens a lot of the time
with tumors and so we employed some
melanoma cells
and added them to the bottom perfusion
Channel
um
and we added both unstimulated as well
as stimulated T cells and what we saw
was that there was quite some migration
of of the T cells only in the situation
when we had the tumors in that bottom
perfusion channel so our bottom right
most graph shows that distance of travel
of the T cells and you can see that yeah
the only those conditions that had the
the tumor cells present
did the cells actually make it to that
bottom tumor compartment
and you can see there was a bit of a
difference in the the T cells and where
they landed based on whether they were
unstimulated or stimulated so those that
were stimulated it seemed that many kind
of remained in that middle gel Channel
well
um for the the unstimulated T cells they
almost
only were within the tumor compartment
and so here we've just Quantified that
in a different way so in this case just
counted the number of T cells that made
it all the way to that bottom Channel
and you can see that there there's
really fewer of those stimulated T cells
present in the tumor compartment and
that's because they're they're in that
ECM Channel
so really those melanoma cells interact
and attract T cells differently
depending on the activation state of the
T cells
okay the last thing I want to wrap up
with is just to let you know that these
migration assays are also compatible
with other endothelial cell types as
well as other organoplates so we've
employed the organoplate 3 Lane 64.
um
and used instead the hubex this is a
pretty commonly used endothelial line
um and in this case we were able to
observe some really nice migration of
the cells after 24 hours into the ECM
with the addition of the cxcl12
okay so really to conclude I hope you
can see that the organoplate
is really a tool that enables us to
study immune cell
extravasation as well as infiltration
so we we demonstrated hopefully the
suitability of the organoplate to study
the process of trans endothelial
migration of the immune cells hopefully
I showed you that it's easy to use that
it's quite customizable there are a
number of things that that you can
measure that we showed today and so I
think those are the first couple just
extravasation
migration distance intervisation
um killing of the cancer cells and then
I have a couple more that are
highlighted here in italics that that we
haven't done ourselves but I tried to
cite some other folks that have worked
with the model I'm including broch and
AstraZeneca who have done some insilico
T Cell infiltration and neutrophil
migration so definitely go check those
out
I also want to point out that
I don't think I mentioned it earlier but
the organoplate enables us to use really
low volumes of media cells growth
factors Etc so it really helps to keep
the cost down and to really to get a lot
of use out of your materials and then of
course for high content Imaging based so
in enabling some some really robust
Imaging assays
so I think you know we were able to
investigate the contribution of
individual and combined factors to
immune cell extravasation so we showed
that activation State inflammations
um chemokines and tumor cells were able
to
interact and drive immune cell migration
in different ways
and finally
we were able to at least begin to assess
some of the pharmacological effects or
at least I think you can see the
groundwork that's laid for that already
right we had the one slide showing that
we're able to inhibit immune cell
migration I think that's particularly
relevant in autoimmune diseases but you
can also imagine that such a model and
platform might be might enable you to
investigate some more immuno
oncology-based drugs where maybe you
want to increase the migration or
perhaps even T-cell killing
[Music]
so I think to wrap up today's talk I
hope you can see that we're already in
my we're already modeling immune cell
migration
um in the organoplating capturing this
in a lot of different ways with a number
of different assays and many of these
are immune and inflammation focused but
I really encourage you to kind of
take this talk digest it a little bit
and really think about how
you know what's important to you and
your immune cell migration assays and
and whether the organoplate could be a
useful tool for you
so with that I'd like to thank all of my
colleagues at momedis as well as our
collaborators around the world
[Music]
thank you all for your time and I'm
happy to take any questions you have